the problem is because richy C said I'm
not going to do it and instead did an
hour meeting on the NHS with officials
nothing was discussed so what he really
wanted to talk about boats and Gaza
there was no you know communication
between the two sides and therefore it's
quite quickly led to accusations that
R's very brittle um labor is saying it
shows he's not serious um lab really
wanted to land this idea he's a taty
prime minister and so you know he just
threw his toys at the pram the counter
to this uh the other Theory by the way
is that this is a you know a long-term
strategy to start a culture War by
number 10 though I think if you are
looking for a culture war of Mass Appeal
for their target voors you potentially
wouldn't start with the Elgen marbles um
you might go for something else given I
think polling suggests only about 15% of
the country really want the AL marbles
to stay here feel that strongly about it
I think Richie was annoyed because he
felt as though he had been led up the
Garden Path and agreement was broken and
also I think that he does actually have
quite strong views on the El marbles